and welcome to hannity and tonight we
start with the fox news alert eric trump
will join us in a moment live he was
with his dad all day today he'll give us
an inside scoop first a dark day for our
republic the department of justice the
rule of law what looks to be potentially
a shocking overreach we'll find out in
due time that will have serious
ramifications
potentially for many many years to come
now biden's politically charged we've
already chronicled all this doj is now
being used as a weapon against biden's
top political rival that's the former
president of the united states of
america donald trump earlier today the
fbi raided the former president's
florida home mar-a-lago while he was in
new york according to president trump
the agent swarmed his residence
unannounced breaking into the home and
even his personal safe in a statement
the 45th president wrote
my beautiful home is currently under
siege rated and occupied by a large
group of fbi agents he continued quote
nothing like this has ever happened to
the president of the united states
before after working and cooperating
with the relevant government agencies
this unannounced rate on my home was not
necessary or appropriate it is
prosecutorial misconduct the
weaponization of the justice system and
an attack by the radical left democrats
who desperately do not want me to run
for president in 2024. according to the
new york times tonight who got the scoop
first somehow the search was focused on
documents that the former president
brought with him from the white house
including potentially classified
documents sources are now telling fox
news that the raid was not related in
any way to january 6 but according to
one source the fbi was quote not being
judicious about what they took during
the search just so we are clear this
raid is truly completely unprecedented
and you can't imagine this what would
have ever happened to a democrat this is
where americans now begin to ask the
question do we have a dual justice
system in america is there equal justice
under the law do we have equal
applications of our laws remember
hillary clinton's house it was never
raided even though she stored troves of
classified material on a personal server
she deleted 33 000 emails remember
nobody had ever heard a bleach bit
before hillary clinton and then there
were hammers involved with with devices
and sim cards that were missing how
about the dirty unverifiable russian
dossier that hillary clinton paid for
being used to lie to a fisa court to spy
on a then presidential candidate later
or president what about the high-ranking
doj officials that signed what was says
at the top of a fisa warrant verified
but they signed their name to something
that was unverifiable and has now been
completely debunked and claimed before
judges that it was verified it wasn't
and then there's joe biden on tape the
real quid pro quo bragging that he
withheld a billion taxpayer dollars you
have six hours uh to fire a ukrainian
prosecutor who he turns out was
investigating his son hunter who is
being paid millions of dollars with no
experience at all whatsoever hunter lies
on a gun application what happened to
hunter nothing what if it was don junior
what if it was eric trump on tape you
have uh of course honor biden smoking
crack and with hookers i think those
things are illegal what happened to him
nothing we had director ray uh before
congress last week they have had
hunter's laptop longer than anybody what
have they done with it nothing millions
of dollars paid to hunter from ukraine
russia a 1.5 billion dollar deal with
the bank of china a hundred thousand
dollar shopping spree with a with a
chinese national no experience nothing
happens joe on tape bragging again and
again i've never ever ever discussed my
son's foreign business dealings well we
know of at least 14 occasions now and we
have pictures in some cases with joe
hunter and guess what hunters farm
business partners nothing happens to
them the bidens have never had their
homes raided they literally sold access
to the highest levels of our government
the big guy was taking his 10 percent
cut according to his own son's laptop
and yet president biden has never faced
legal scrutiny it's not even clear that
his son hunter who has literally
recorded his crimes in great detail will
ever get charged with any crime no raid
to his house but if your last name is
roger stone or if your name is paul
manafort you got a pre-dawn raid guns
drawn fbi swat team pointing guns in
your face
a process crime and cnn cameras to boot
they just happen to be there at 5 30 a.m
to film it all if you peter navarro you
get put in handcuffs and leg shackles
and hauled away from an airport
for a charge of a misdemeanor we saw the
same heavy-handed tactics with general
flynn carter page paul manafort pre-dawn
raid guns drawn and so many others make
no mistake if you're associated with
donald trump in any way you better cross
all your eyes and dot all your t's
because they're coming for you with the
full force of the federal government
they will break down your front door
they will spire in your text and your
phone calls they will charge you with
every process crime in the book they'll
throw you in leg chains and handcuffs
and they'll stick guns in your face at 5
30 in the morning just to send a message
why doesn't this ever happen to a
democrat equal justice under the law is
it dead
equal application of our laws is that
dead has our department of justice been
turned into a political weapon and if
they can do this to president trump what
do you think they can do to the rest of
us we'll have full breaking coverage all
night long hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else